today on stick to football Conor and I
are breaking it all down we are looking
at the trade deadline looking at the
hottest teams and we're gonna give you a
top ten mock draft because the draft
order keeps changing week by week teams
are on hot streak some teams on losing
streaks but Connor my man we have to
tailgate tour events coming up very very
soon that we're very excited about yeah
we are cuz we are leaving for London at
the end of this week which is a huge one
so that's Sunday from four to six or
four to whenever you know how we do it
on the tailgate tour Matt we just hang
around as long as we want watching the
games we're gonna be at O'Neill's in
London so if you're looking to hang out
with us for the games you know where to
find us left go is gonna be with us
we're gonna do a podcast sometime in
that four to six window and then when
things really get rockin for all the
games at six o'clock we'll be hanging
out having a good time with everyone and
then after that on November 9th what can
really be billed as maybe the
prerequisite to the national title game
in college football this year we're
gonna be on the quad in Tuscaloosa for
Alabama LSU so if you are gonna be there
for Alabama LSU probably the two best
teams in the country right now
besides Ohio State they got to be in the
mix too these teams are gonna play each
other we're gonna be tailgating we're
net food drinks whatever so come find us
on the quad on November 9th yeah it's
gonna be a good time we are all praying
for to his ankle because we will hit
that one and good luck Connor cuz now
Clemson fans are gonna be in your
mentions because I tweeted the other day
that Clemson don't care they should be
number five they should be maybe number
six Clemson fans like you remember last
year and he said that we beat Notre Dame
they listen fellas I never pick Notre
Dame to beat you I was like the biggest
Notre Dame a hater last year so calm
yourselves Clemson you're not that good
this year
alright let's go around the league
though because the NFL Sunday was just
insane you had the Niners winning in the
mud a nine nothing game over the
Redskins
yeah Jalen Ramsey's first game with the
Rams Marcus Peters first game with the
Ravens but it's really the story of the
young quarterbacks in the league right
now like either good ones or the bad
ones the Cardinals have won three
straight
Kliff Kingsbury has a better winning
percentage right now in the NFL than he
did in college
because they are three three and one
Kyler yesterday against the Giants
I feel like an uneven performance but
he's getting the job done and he's also
we're starting to see his threat as a
runners opening things up for chase
Edmunds is opening things up for what
they're doing on the outside passing
game
I think Kingsbury starting to find his
stride a little bit as we get to mid
season yeah I think so too I think
what's interesting about this Cardinals
team is obviously a huge risk on both
ends the coaching higher the traffic
that came with it but I think we're
seeing not only the offense become a
little more aggressive which had to
happen we talked about it after a couple
weeks that for Kyler it was kind of
becoming checked down Charlie situation
where listen the reason we liked him so
much was his ability to extend plays and
push the football down the field and now
I think we're seeing a little bit of
that but I also think finally Matt this
defense came to life a little bit I went
back and watched I think it was eight
sacks against Daniel jones yesterday and
some of them were clearly his fault of
not seeing the rush right in his face or
holding the ball a little too long but
some of them were really good pass rush
attempts are really good calls on the
defensive end where I know this isn't
the most talented defensive unit and
they have a lot of rebuilding to do
these next couple years but they're
playing hard for a a very I don't want
to say questionable coaching hire but
bold coaching hire yeah I think we're
seeing early that Kliff Kingsbury can
handle an NFL locker room and that's a
great sign for Arizona yeah and I think
the key with cliff like let's just and I
want to say that I know a lot of people
think that because cliff was at Texas
Tech like maybe we don't like him
because Melo and I are such big Texas
fans I'm rooting for Kliff Kingsbury I
think anytime innovation can come to the
NFL we want that to succeed I hope that
it can be sustainable because one thing
that happens with NFL coverages we all
get caught up in the moment and it's
like the big picture it's like okay the
Patriots are gonna end up good you know
like everyone's like kind of comes back
to the center on us Oh hopefully it
happens hopefully the Cardinals were
able to stay ahead of that because I do
really like where they're they're out
offensively the other side of that they
beat the New York Giants who are just
reeling right now to move to Daniel
Jones it was like okay they got a little
bit of a spark but they've lost three
straight now it's a team
is negative 55 employed differential
this year there one in three at home the
Giants are bad it's not just Daniel
jones fault the defense is horrible and
that is I think alarming because they
spent two first-round picks on Dexter
Lawrence and John J Baker you would like
to see them making a bigger impact and
also because I feel like this is a team
where would you know James Becher's the
defensive coordinator it's like okay
they they really we really expected this
team to be better than they are right
now yeah I guess offensive I don't yeah
defensively for sure I definitely did
I think say Kwan didn't look a hundred
percent this weekend too which is very
frustrating to me because I almost felt
like the Giants went into this game and
I'm not saying assuming a win but
assuming it would be a little bit easier
and Arizona looked so much hungrier in
this game I think you know when it comes
down to it Pat Shermer is not a good
decision maker he's not I didn't like
this hire I thought he had a really
tough first round tenure as an NFL head
coach I don't think he's improved pretty
much at all I you run a draw on third
and 18 with three minutes left in the
game you're down three points you put
your rookie quarterback who had been on
the turf the entire day playing in the
rain in a fourth and 15 situation what
do you think is gonna happen it's just
it's just time and time again bad
decisions from Pat Shermer even if you
believe in the daniel Jones pick or not
the guy calling the shots there and Dave
gentlemen does and I think at the end of
the day if he wants this to have any
chance of succeeding in the next two
years because that's all you get when
you take a guy in the top ten you get
two to three years we're gonna be going
into year two very soon in the blink of
an eye the Giants have to be in this
conversation for the Lincoln riley's of
the world and all of these other coaches
that everybody wants know exactly and I
know well I don't want to keep like
going back to what we said because I
don't know if people really care about
that but sure I was looking forward
right when Pat Shermer was hired we
trashed that hiring because it was
boring it was uninspiring in the New
York Giants
that's a blueblood franchise you could
get at that time you know this is great
ownership this is a stable franchise at
the
I thought they could have made a but a
much better hire if you fire pat Shermer
are you really gonna get Lincoln Riley
to the Giants I don't know if you are
anymore like I do I don't I don't think
so like they don't feel like they have
that much prestige anymore maybe Daniel
jones changes that it just takes one
person to love Daniel Jones and say okay
I want to work with that guy but right
now it doesn't look great it was good to
see sake Wambach but man they they have
a lot of holes to fill and we're gonna
talk about that when we do our top ten
mock draft in the next segment
the Bears oh my god the Bears uh here's
where well start this I tweeted this
Sunday night and it got some mixed
reviews but I would just like to
officially say on the podcast on YouTube
to everyone watching and listening
I was wrong about Mitch strabinsky I had
him as QB one in that class I felt like
you know one year starter at UNC who was
accurate and athletic and smart it was
like he's only going to get better with
more reps and was NFL coaching that has
not been the case and that is the risk
when you draft on potential true Biscay
has not lived up to it and it could cost
people their jobs in Chicago I feel like
Matt and Aggie and Ryan pace should be
somewhat safe I'd like to see them
letting Aggie pick his own quarterback
but makes it a first-round pick so
that's what makes this one really tough
and I know naggy came out I believe
Sunday and said he will not allow the
media to divide his team Matt we're not
trying to divide your team we're trying
to tell you your quarterback sucks like
that's I agree and I think the whole
media comment was a really bad look
because they got bigger problems than
the media telling the truth about this
football team right now I love this play
calling last year I don't understand it
at all this year they barely get sorry
Cohen involved they barely get the run
game going I know they have injuries on
the offensive line
sure whiskey's been really really bad
you can only ask your defense to carry
you so many weeks before they burn out
of being on the field or trying to score
points and overcompensate so many times
and I think this transitions to our next
point Matt because you said listen for
this head coach in Matt naggy he's gonna
hopefully get the chance to pick his
next quarterback was their next
quarterback across the field from them
on Sunday and Teddy Bridgewater I wonder
about that
Teddy's five I know which I'm gonna pat
myself
the back people are watching he's back
miraculously I mean he's five and oh and
I feel like they've taken the training
wheels off those first two wins it was
like okay Teddy don't mess up without
alvin kamara and they were doing it with
some fun play calling michael thomas is
unstoppable right now wide reciever I
don't know if Teddy will leave I don't
know if Sean Payton will want him to yes
he's a free agent after this year and
the Saints can't afford to give him big
starter money but they need to have a
conversation with Drew Brees about how
much longer do you plan to play we used
to talk about this with Jimmy Garoppolo
the Patriots needed to have a
conversation with Tom how long do you
want to play because we got a guy that
we like and we either need to keep him
if you're gonna leave or we need to let
him go be a player somewhere else and
make you know fifteen to twenty to
twenty five million dollars a year I
feel like with Teddy it's the same thing
it breathes yep he's gonna come back and
play well Teddy needs to go to Denver or
Chicago or Tennessee somewhere here
where he can be a starter again and make
that starter money he's making a seven
and a half million right now it's not
not the worst place to be and he's
winning a lot of ballgames but I think
old Teddy two gloves is gonna be looking
to be a starter somewhere
I wouldn't go to Chicago if I were him
because he has struggled in the elements
at times I would look at a place like
Tennessee where maybe they don't want
another game manager kind of quarterback
but that fits what he is better than
going to a Denver or a Chicago we're
gonna have to deal with the cold and the
wind there's a guy not a very strong arm
like he is a south or west coast
quarterback and a couple things with
Teddy he'll be only 27 years old and
free agency next year he's still 26 I'll
turn 27 in November I think he the
reports came out that he had the
opportunity to go be the starter in
Miami thank you Lord Jesus Christ he was
smart enough to dodge that bullet and
there was also a lot of reports that he
returned in New Orleans because there
are some belief that he can be the
successor for Drew Brees I think in a
perfect world here Matt because they can
get out of the contract after this year
with Brees the Saints win the Super Bowl
this year and Brees retires and Teddy is
the future I think if you're a Saints
fan that's the perfect world scenario
that is the absolute perfect scenario
yeah and I hope it happens because it
would be great for Teddy great for Brees
Saints have a young offensive core
between the offensive line between
michael thomas alvin kamara where teddy
he'll step right in he's like I've won a
ton of games here already let's just
keep this thing moving but we're gonna
keep our show movin here
the Colts with a gigantic win against
the Houston Texans I was very wrong
about this game I was surprised the
Texans weren't favored I thought - Shaun
Watson would put the team on his back
which he always does week after week but
you have to be pretty happy if you're a
Colts fan with the play of Jacoby
Brissette so far absolutely have to be
and I again I tweeted this that Sunday
Chris Ballard looks like a genius
because he traded for Jacoby when Luck
was hurt and he kind of held down the
fort then luck comes back and it you
know looked like it an MVP candidate
through much of 2018 then he suddenly
retires and everyone's left like oh god
one of the Colts got into a quarterback
let's talk about 2020 quarterback
prospects they don't need to because
they really liked you Kobe percent which
is why they gave him the extension they
did before the season and you know it's
a credit to to Jacoby as a credit to
Frank Reich Marlin Mac is playing out of
his mind the offensive lines playing
well and the defense is planning
incredibly well you know I saw this team
in person against the Kansas City Chiefs
when this you know they really like it
fell like the season turned for them
they've won two straight and it's really
because of guys like Darius Leonard it's
because the front seven on defense it's
because of Marlon Mac but it's also
because Brissette a lot like teddy
bridgewater like he's not turning the
ball over he's not making mistakes he's
setting the table for his offense and
then when he needs to he can go out
score some teams so I I really really
like what what they have there
especially because for the next couple
years he's an inexpensive option so
there's a team of the most available
salary cap space of anyone in the NFL
they can go being very aggressive if
they want to this offseason yeah they
were looking really smart right now
after giving him that you know bridge
kind of extension of two years where it
doesn't put them in this position at the
end of the year - hey we got a roll
which of Kobe for the next four with a
monster' extension or not now they have
time to evaluate him in this two-year
window for mediocre money and keep this
thing rolling they got Eric Ebron
involved in the offense again and with
their lack of overall weapons I think he
is somebody you live with the drops it's
an
that'll always be Hui Bron is but it was
nice to see him get involved yesterday
so the Colts I mean what a story right
now talk about disaster over summer and
they are really rolling and you have to
feel really good if you're a Colts fan
about your front office and about your
quarterback one more team on the round
the league here because they're just a
mess from top to bottom they really and
I'm shocked because I thought this team
would win 12 football games this year
the Philadelphia Eagles matt is this
team in a fixable correctable situation
this year you know I don't think so and
I picked them to win the NFC East so I'm
right there with you and actually I had
them in the Super Bowl
I had them losing but I had them in the
Super Bowl I thought you know Carson
Wentz with this defense and it's just
been it's falling apart you know they
need help a wide receiver they need help
at corner
they tried to trade for Jalen Ramsey
Adam Schefter reported they offered a
first in a second that didn't get the
job done I don't know that I don't know
if there's anyone out there and we are
going to talk about the trade deadline
and a little bit here but I don't know
if there's anyone out there you could
trade for that's gonna fix this team I
really don't you know we sold your scene
anderson talked last week about there's
people upset with carson wentz they're
upset with the front office for not
getting Jalen Ramsey it almost feels
like there's like they need to turn this
thing over in the offseason that it's
not so much an in season improvement you
can make you might all you might have to
like draw a line and be like these are
the these are Doug Peterson's guys these
are high rose ones guys these are Carson
Wentz's guys we're gonna build with them
and everybody else we're gonna have to
find a way to replace because you just
you have a mutiny in the locker room and
it just feels like a team that you know
since they beat the Patriots in the
Super Bowl it has kind of struggled with
some of that once wince came back as the
starter yeah there's no doubt about that
and I think even some of the effort
situations Nelson Aguilar not laying out
for that deep ball last night I could
not even not even extending and you sit
there and you go this is somebody who's
been highly criticized this year I was
mind blown by that play and I'll say
this I think this football team believe
it or not is an entirely different team
without DeSean Jackson when he is on the
field they can push the ball vertically
they give their guys their running backs
room in the box he's been out with that
abdomen injury for a couple weeks now
and they just look entirely entirely
they're a team that needs a vertical
threat I know last year they called the
Jets about Robbie Anderson but they only
offered our fourth or a third-round pick
the Jets are not doing that and right
now it's that connection Samms Arnold
and him have I don't think Robbie
Anderson will be on the trade block
either so the Eagles and we're gonna get
into trade talk and how they can fix
this thing but it is a very very
critical situation right now
it can't be Monday without mock draft
Monday we're gonna give you the top ten
teams because Connor and I are both
picking for them not the back-and-forth
that you usually get and based on the
current standings which everyone always
gets mad about these but this is the
current standings all right if the draft
were today this is what the order would
be this is not a prediction the
Cincinnati Bengals would own the first
pick in the draft Connor and I would
have them taking two even with the ankle
injury everyone I talked to says this is
qb1 it's not even really a conversation
at this point now he has been hurt two
years in a row which I think you do
worry about a little bit but to his
touch his accuracy his toughness his
football IQ he doesn't have a strongest
arm in the world but I think a lot like
a Drew Brees like a Steve Young it's
what he's able to do in terms of
placement and anticipation that really
makes him special yeah I'm with you
there I'm not changing this one up it's
two at number one for me and I know a
lot of people will want Joe burrow into
this conversation I don't think he's
there yet in terms of on to his level
now the staying healthy will always be
key for him but that accuracy at all
three levels of the field is what
separates to a tumble by Lowa from the
pack here and I think for the bengals
with Zach Taylor system they're gonna be
looking to get that quarterback in place
of the future I think they will move on
from Andy Dalton if they're picking
first overall because they'll have this
opportunity to land that franchise
quarterback and right now we've said it
all your Matt we're not moving off a two
at this spot no we're not and at number
two the Miami Dolphins look at this
situation and say okay what do we do
here do you take a generational pass
rusher and chase young do you what what
do you do and they would pick again
right now at number 10 so and a lot of
my mock drafts I've had them taking
chase young and said okay we'll get the
quarterback down the road but here's the
deal
Joe burrow was shooting into the
stratosphere like a freaking rocket I
have them taking Joe burrow at number
two
and I don't think this is a reach I have
burrow right now at number five overall
on my big board if you have a
quarterback at five you draft him at two
and you don't worry about it
burrow is making big place down the
field and a lot of people are gonna want
to give credit to his receiver core with
Justin Jefferson with Jamar chase his
receiving core is not better than to us
it's not better than Trevor Lawrence's
it's probably not better than che
Patterson's they're good but they're not
in an elite tier it definitely not by
themselves in any elite tier so what
borough is doing in Joe Brady's offense
we're seeing him throw the ball down the
field we're seeing it make plays with
his legs he's tough
he's smart he's got some swag to him so
I absolutely love Joe Burrell as
everyone knows I feel comfortable giving
him to the dolphins - yeah as do I it's
crazy I mean he's the most improved
player in college football and the most
improved player in this draft sphere
right now now I think with burrow the
questions are probably gonna be overall
arm talent and I think it's looked
really good this year but just overall
arm talent how he is throwing compared
to guys like to a Herbert and Eason and
number two for me will probably be age I
think he's on the older spectrum for a
quarterback prospect after being a
transfer from Ohio State and now to your
starter for LSU but if you believe in
the player and you believe in the traits
and you heard it last week from Jim
naggy he's gonna interview really really
well with teams own the room you should
believe that Joe burrow can be the pick
in this spot to lead this Miami Dolphins
rebuild I absolutely agree at number
three the Washington Redskins I'm gonna
surprise people here and remember mock
drafts are for me are always based on
what I hear especially as we get into
this time of year not what I would do I
would draft chase young so fast that the
league wouldn't even realize I'd made
the pick I go we're taking him chase
young right we're on the clock but I
think Washington is there a need based
drafting team as long as the current
front office is there that's what
they're gonna do so I believe they would
take Andrew Thomas to this spot because
of the Trent Williams disaster I think
they're gonna try to pin a lot of this
year's problems on the fact that Trent
Williams is holding out so I think they
draft Andrew Thomas here again not what
I would do just what I'm hearing they
really like montes what they drafted him
in the first last year they like Ryan
Kerrigan even as he's getting a
little bit older so I look at this team
and they have Ryan Anderson as well who
was to the second round pick in 2017 so
when you look at this team it's like yes
they everyone could use chase young but
their need at left tackle and what the
current front office is doing they could
absolutely need him and don't forget
Brandon Scherff is a free agent after
this year so they get happy needs all
across this offensive line that they
could franchise sure if they could try
to keep him but that's a Pro Bowl level
right guard that could be getting loose
as well yeah without a doubt he's gonna
get big-time money we know that I'm
gonna keep it pretty simple here and go
with chase young I think he's just too
good to pass up now in Washington
sometimes the obvious isn't always the
answer for them so I wouldn't be
surprised if they go your route instead
Matt but for me chase young is just the
best player in this draft right now I
think he's coming very close to reaching
that Knick Bosa and miles garret level
don't have him there yet I think he's
very very close and I'm sure the final
grades he'll be right there he's a game
wrecker he is the definition of a game
wrecker what he can do off the edge his
IQ playing the run and even against slip
screens we've seen him be very patient
he reads quarterbacks very well he's got
the length he's got the strength he
pushes the pocket he wins with
elusiveness and Ben's
I love chase young and I think
Washington you just need good football
players right now they really do they
absolutely do and at number four overall
the Atlanta Falcons which I cannot
believe how bad this team is I neither
can i with all the talent do they have
you have Matt Ryan Julio Jones Calvin
Ridley you got first rounders across the
board on defense and they absolutely
suck and our buddy Jim naggy tweeted
Sunday they're the Falcons who benched
Matt Ryan on Sunday they called it an
ankle injury but I think that benched
him he tweeted they're gonna be looking
at quarterbacks early in 2020 and I
actually agree and I'm giving them just
in a Herbert here because it's gonna be
a new head coach hell it might be a new
general manager here I love what Thomas
Dimitrov has done
we haven't Scott Pioli is his assistant
for a long time was remarkable but
they're not seeing a great return on
investment with many of those picks
their shopping guys like Vic Beasley
Tech McKinley hasn't become the guy they
expected him to be they drafted two
offensive linemen in the first round
last year
neither's playing at a very high level
yet so Alex we could see a new regime in
Atlanta
I know Arthur Blank is notoriously
patient and loyal but it could be time
to turn this around Matt Ryan you can
get out of his contract after 2021
easily so this could be a deal where you
draft the quarterback comment Eli
Manning Daniel Jones you're drafting
your quarterback of the future in a
really good quarterback class and then
you're looking at Matt Ryan's not a
young guy anymore either and what I mean
he's 34 so when that deal when you can
get out I mean he's at the end of his
career pretty much I think it's time for
them to start thinking about what's
coming next at quarterback man I think
they'd be absolutely insane if they put
any of the blame on Matt Ryan and I know
that's a case more of the point is Matt
for you is that if new people come in
and take over
they might view it that they want their
own guy I think this team has way bigger
problems than Matt Ryan I'm gonna go
with Geoff Okuda here from Ohio State
get some help in the secondary and an
elite talent in the secondary this
defense from top to bottom whether it's
the secondary whether it's the front
four whether it's the linebackers
they've been embarrassing and they are
worse than the Miami Dolphins defense
right now that's how bad they've been
they're poorly coached they're poorly
prepared the talent doesn't look
anything like it used to so Jeff Okuda
grab the best offensive player available
on the board I think they have so many
problems that have to do with
preparation and coaching like you set up
the top of this one right now Matt they
have talent they have talent to turn
this thing around it will be with a
different coaching staff and I think
that coaching staff will want a premier
corner talent like a CUDA
I love Jeffrey Kakuta absolutely love
him he is without a doubt a top-five
player in this class and I'm gonna get
to him in a little bit your newer Jets
are at number five and this happens to
you guys every damn year you know like
there we go again we picked fourth or
fifth and a player falls to us that
there's no way up to this players fall
to us I have chase young falling here
chase young is my number one player he
is he's better than the BOCES he is on
par with Miles Garrett for me as a
prospect I love chase young so when you
see this or hear this don't start
tweeting Miller hates chase young I love
him but weird things happen in the NFL
Draft especially with three quarterbacks
going in the top four chase young should
he fall no couldif all yes crazier
things have happened
and if he falls the Jets have to be the
happiest people in the entire world
because this fills their biggest need
with the best player in the class man I
absolutely love it it would be the Jets
first edge rusher since John Abraham so
let's go go get chase young I'm gonna go
on the offensive side of the ball since
I already took chase young and I feel
just like you do Matt Jerri Judy here
how is Jerry Judy sitting here at five
overall Sam Donald's new best friend
this would be Sam Darnell's Julio Jones
kind of version here will he'll be with
the team for the next ten years number
one wide receiver the offense funnels
through him if you go into the 2020
season with levy on in the backfield you
still have Robbie as a deep threat
hopefully you can bring him back Crowder
in the slot and Jerry Judy as your
number one wide receiver with Chris
Herndon that tight end I think that
might be good enough to keep Adam GaSe
around for a little bit that's how
exciting that offense would be god I
can't leave Judea stone the port it's
like that's the great thing about mock
drafts it's like crazy things do happen
that's why we do this over and over
again exactly so at number six I'm
giving the New York Giants Jerry Judy
you lose the draft his little brother
you know this is basically you're
getting another version of obj they do
have needs across the board I thought
about going off and supplying here and
obviously the defense needs a lot of
help Dave gentlemen is always preferred
drafting the like offensive line and
defensive line and linebackers you have
to change things up this year to give
Daniel Jones like he's so Sam Donald
give Daniel Jones his new best friend
that Jerry Judy no matter where he lands
he is that scheme fluid he can work in
any scheme just get him out there
running routes the man as I put in the
scouting notebook Friday starting to a
scouting buddy and he was like Jerry
Judy's a glitch that's what he is man
he's not it's not fair how good he is at
the receiver position and I'm going with
the offensive line like you mentioned
Andrew Thomas here for the New York
Giants let's just call it like it is nay
solder wasn't was a horrific free-agent
addition yes he was an upgrade from Eric
flowers but you gave him a four-year
mega contract with guarantees into about
75% of the deal he's not getting it done
he's not very good Andrew Thomas is very
good the Giants need offensive line help
for Daniel Jones to make this offense
work and injured Thomas is kind of an
ass kicker in the run game where you can
get sake
on the outside and give him some space
to work with so looking at this board
for these two New York teams to the Jets
and the Giants at five and six
they RNA can't lose situation at those
spots of the draft yeah it's you're
really in a great spot in this class
because the quarterback rise is gonna
happen at number seven we have the LA LA
chargers my goodness on the board
another team that I think has to look at
quarterback of the future Phillip Rivers
another guy getting older they have
struggled this year this is a team that
you don't expect to be in the top ten
very often so I think when you are you
have to think about drafting ahead I
love rivers and I know we've said before
there have been reports that he is not
the kind of guy that wants to mentor a
young quarterback he might not have a
choice he and his nine children might
just have to watch the Chargers draft
someone I'm going Jordan love here
someone that hasn't made me been talked
about as much in the last two weeks but
there has been buzz in the scouting
community and of course it's early but
there's been buzz that he is a better
quarterback prospect than twoa and a
better quarterback prospect than Joe
Barrow I disagree with that but I think
you have to give some credibility to
those comments and that there could be
teams that prefer Jordan love skill set
he's got a big arm he can run around and
make plays I don't know if I've said
this on the podcast or not watching him
play reminds me of Kaepernick at Nevada
like let's not kneeling Kaepernick but
like Kaepernick with Jim Harbaugh or
when he was in college would Chris all
like his ability to move around and make
plays his arm strength it may be not
quite two caps level but nevertheless a
very very strong arm so I didn't join in
Love has a great chance to put himself
in the top ten I feel like we do this
every year with the Chargers where we
were doing it in the deshaun Watson here
should listen where and they should have
they should have done this a couple of
times and I love Phillip Rivers and I
still think Phillip Rivers is good but
like you said Matt at some point you got
to start thinking quarterback but they
just refused to do it and for that
reason I went with Derek Brown here from
Auburn when he returned for a senior
year I kind of raised my eyebrow to it
and was like man I don't think he needs
to do that I think he'd be a first-round
pick without going back to school he has
gone back to school and had the Josh
Allen effect where it's like okay this
guy's a first ran a fringe first-round
defensive lineman now he looks like a
top 10
player I mean he looks phenomenal and I
think he'll go to the Senior Bowl being
in Mobile Alabama and just kick the [ __ ]
out of everyone I love Derrick brown the
Chargers keep getting tougher on defense
I hate that everyone that goes there
seems to get hurt it's just awful awful
luck but if you're looking for a pure
talent in this spot
Derrick Brown would be a really nice
pick for them I wish we could draft a
team doctor for the Chargers yeah cannot
at number eight the Denver Broncos I'm
not giving them a quarterback because I
do think they believe in true lock now
if John Elway gets fired all bets are
off and this could be a free agent
destination who knows Cam Newton might
be here next year there's a lot of
different directions they could go
I'm gonna go corner Chris Harris jr. is
gonna be out after this year some are
placing him with our guy Jeff Okuda who
we talked about a little bit earlier in
the show he is a top-five player for me
I've met number four overall he's one of
the best corners that I've evaluated in
a long time I like him better than I
liked Marshawn Lattimore or Denzel Ward
and Denzel Ward was the number four pick
in a pretty good draft class I didn't
really kuda 6:1 200 pounds I've compared
him to Jalen Ramsey I do believe that
you're getting that type of fire that
type of physicality at the corner
position and a guy who can travel he
could play either side he's very very
good at man coverage Okuda is a
no-brainer for the Broncos if he's
available I love that addition there if
he is available on that board just in
case John Elway is not running this team
which almost seems like the impossible
at this point but if he's not I think a
new regime would come in and say listen
you took true lock in the second round
we'll let them fight it in camp but
we're only going to be picking in this
top 10 so many times and Justin
Herbert's on the board me and you are
very honest about this Justin Herbert
scares the hell out of us no matter what
is coached it says the defend him even
in a win against Washington where that
final no call at the end of the game
might have saved Oregon honestly it
looks like pass interference to me
Herbert just looks kind of broken down
in big pressure moments but talent sells
teams and Herbert has a lot of talent
he's mobile he has a big arm the splash
plays are as good as it gets and I think
for that reason he's going to end up
going in the top ten of this draft yeah
that's all it takes I mean someone's
gonna fall in love with Herbert I flew
II absolutely believe that the Cleveland
Browns number nine we actually agree on
this pick the M
I haven't haven't had one of those in a
little bit here but we agree they need
off in supply and help Tristan wharfs
the right tackle at Iowa makes a ton of
sense for them I know a lot of people
think he can play on the left side in
the NFL without any problems they need
to help with both sides so it really
doesn't matter where you want him to
play he's gonna be a great fit for them
and then at number 10 the Miami Dolphins
they they have this pick because of the
trade from Mika Fitzpatrick the Steelers
we'll see if they continue to win and
this pick goes down into the teens more
but I have them going receiver CD lamb
here I love Henry lugs
Henry rugs excuse me and I love CD lamb
it's tough to separate those two even
though they're completely different
players but I went with lamb I think
he's just a little better fit for what
but at least what I've heard that like
Chris Grier and those guys valuing a
receiver he is incredibly tough he's
physical over the middle he's aggressive
after the catch rugs has for two speed
and you can't coach that you can't
discount that I think lamb is just a
better fit for this particular team
these are guys I have them ranked 11 and
12 overall and they're you're splitting
hairs with these two you really are and
for me what CD I still have them in the
conversation for the number one overall
wide receiver in this class but I'm
gonna take a little different route here
for the Dolphins and give them Henry
rugs because of what you said mat the
speed element the four to speed they
took Joe burrow at number two from both
of us in this mock draft now they get a
vertical threat and Henry rugs if you
want to see that speed on display again
watch the interception chase down from
Henry rugs it's like a cheetah
oh my going across this like a blur
across the screen but rugs is a great
wide receiver you can't go wrong with
either of these guys for whoever young
quarterback they select at the top of
this draft it is draft on draft time
y'all and we've got four great questions
today trying to spread it around so keep
sending those questions if you has tech
draft on draft I'm gonna see it and
tweet deck or counter see it Mellow is
gonna see it and we want to get some new
names on the show so keep sending your
questions even if you've sent some of
the past and we haven't answered it keep
it going because we're gonna need you
especially when the summer gets here so
here's our first question from King
Herms
oh four all right so I'm curious guys
what are your thoughts on Teddy after
this stretch is he the future in New
Orleans and a true franchise quarterback
I know we talked about this a little bit
earlier
but I just want to reiterate again I
think he could be the future on a team
that is built with a good run game in a
strong defense teddy is not gonna be the
answer for a team that wants to air it
out and throw it 40 times a game and
they need to score 50 points but he can
be the answer with a great offensive
line in New Orleans with Alma Kamara
Michael Thomas and with a good defense
but it does come down to salary it comes
down to what drew Brees wants to do 10
he's a free agent it kind of like we
said earlier I could see him end up in
Tennessee if Mike Vrabel says listen
we're not gonna draft a quarterback
we're gonna be picking in the teens or
maybe the 20s we're not trapped in a
quarterback we were probably not gonna
pay a guy that has failed somewhere else
I could see them going after Teddy who's
just gonna be like he used to be solid
he's not gonna turn the ball over and if
you're a defensive mind a head coach
that might be good enough without a
doubt I think Teddy's future next year
is as a starter now true franchise
quarterback is tough to say because
he'll always be the injury scare with
teddy going forward now like I said off
the table he's gonna be 27 as a free
agent that's great very young for a
quarterback very young I think in terms
of money you look at that jacobi per set
cap number for next year it's at 21.5
million I think Teddy you'll see a cap
number right around there Matt I don't
think he's gonna be in that dak Prescott
future kind of range or even that 30
million kind of number per year and that
might be that might make him more
valuable where more teams are asking for
his services because they're saying hey
we could save 1015 million per year on
the cap with the guy we believe we can
win a lot of games with that quarterback
and we can allocate that money to a
receiver an offensive lineman right pass
rusher it makes a big difference and
that's why I think a lot of teams will
believe in Teddy after the season and
it's really exciting now as you know
King herm said here is he the future in
NOLA is the question that everyone wants
to see as another thing we said earlier
in the show if they win a Super Bowl
this year at Drew Brees I wouldn't be
shocked to see drew be like hey and I'm
done this is Teddy's team now maybe not
but he's he's gonna be 41 years old next
year not everyone's Tom Brady and
breezes somebody that now is seeing
injuries where again unfortunately he
had such a long stretch of not being
hurt after a tough start to his career
I think if it was up to Teddy he would
stay in New Orleans I think so I think
he really likes Sean Payton and I was
actually looking because I don't know
have we seen when breeze is coming back
I hurt like maybe next week
now you've no reason to rush him anymore
yeah it could be week 10 because that's
after to buy that's probably when he
comes back but you're right if if Teddy
steers the ship he'll if they go
undefeated with Teddy and then breeze
comes in and they went to Super Bowl I I
could see him riding off into the sunset
calling it calling it quits and then
Teddy stays and and we kind of wait to
see what happens there all right Kevin
Williams if you had to start a new
franchise and had to build it around a
running back in the NFL right now who
would you pick it's Christian McCaffrey
for me and there's really not a debate
anymore like I love se Kwan but I would
take McCaffrey I just would I think what
he brings to the table as a receiver a
runner those two like it's 1a 1b for me
I would be fine with either one but I
watching McCaffrey play is one of my
favorite things in the world I actually
think he's the best receiver on their
team as well as one of the best running
backs in the NFL right now I'm with you
I think it's McCaffrey and then I would
actually have camara as the second guy
on this list would say Kwan being third
and I'll tell you who does not and it's
ridiculous to say this after the kind of
win they had I don't think Zeke looks
the same right now he doesn't look like
those guys where he's making guys miss
all the time or he's being a difference
maker on all three down so it's
interesting how the running back pack
has really separated itself where it's
run CMC at the top I think Camaros right
there kind of with them and sake wands
in that conversation as well of course
when he's healthy and these guys are the
cream of the crop in the NFL right now
yeah I mean you can't go wrong with
chimera it's like he's just hurt right
now that's the only thing but but God
he's amazing all right Patrick
Chamberlain asked I know he's a
sophomore but what are your thoughts on
KJ hammer he's tiny but he's such a
playmaker curious if you have a cop for
him and how you think the NFL will view
him given his size limitations I'll say
this man Marquis Brown was a first-round
pick and accept loss was a first-round
pick and I don't know that size matters
as much as they do like you know as much
as we all have been told that it does I
really don't know if it does because
like you said with KJ like he's so
explosive he's five nine 176 as well I
was
so I was looking up I want to see the
listed I mean yeah he's listed five nine
once every six which I mean tells me he
could probably play at that I am Marquis
Brown is five nine I think he wasn't
like the one sixty he was when Marquis
Brown got to Oklahoma I believe he was
one forty holy God but and then when I'm
pretty sure he was at one sixty going
into his final year there and I think
hammer is probably more like 170 165
yeah I think that that's the comp is
Marquis Brown and Marquis Wade 166 at
the combine so anyways a first round
pick so I think hammer I will see what
you know where his career goes and and I
because he's a sophomore I'm not done a
deep dive on injuries you know but
Marquis had a foot injury still my first
chances yeah maybe you know maybe it
actually doesn't matter you know what
I've gotten better at Matt and this is
something I completely ignored probably
the first three years of doing the draft
is evaluating not guys play sighs but
how they protect themselves on the field
yes it's like hilar Murray Cuyler Murray
is the perfect example did not care how
small he was in terms of injury concerns
because Cuyler Murray will he rarely
take he always goes out of bounds
someone works like with him all the time
he has such a small strike zone he's
hard yes it and so I mean with a handler
it it could be very similar I know
Michigan could tackle em and the motors
gotten better at that
yeah we're Lamar doesn't take the big
hits he'll take contact to get in the
end zone but Lamar doesn't line himself
up at times like you know some of these
guys just refuse to go we've seen once
do that now he got her to needs to do a
much better job Trevor Lawrence Josh
Allen does that a lot
Josh Allen will take big hits Josh is
like 260 so you like he thinks it's okay
yeah Cam Newton said the same thing for
a long time so it's it's a fascinating
part of scouting how do you protect your
body yeah and really like to take that a
step further
not everyone who weighs 170 looks the
same you know I remember when even wince
and golf they weighed the same I stood
next to them side by side they are not
built the same yeah at all like you have
to like throw you know throw away the
the numbers when you look at that
sometimes look at body comp right last
question from our guy Garth is this
quarterback class a chance of being the
most loaded draft class and how many
starters do you believe will eventually
come from it
I I don't know that it's gonna be like
the best that we've ever seen but we
could see six go in the first round
which you know the the Lamar Jackson
that class we saw five go in the first
and there was some time maybe that Mason
Rudolph but anyway this year two is
gonna go in the first round
Joe burrows is gonna go in the first
round Justin a Herbert's gonna go in the
first round I think Jacob Easton has a
very good chance to go in the first
round especially after how well he
played against Oregon jordan loves gonna
go in the first round Jalen Hertz might
go in the first round I mean there's a
lot of dudes out there Jake that's a lot
I don't know if Jake frog comes out I
know a lot of people get upset because I
don't mention him all the time I don't
know if he's gonna come out so if he
comes out yeah I think there's a decent
chance he goes first round I'll say this
and maybe this opinion will try a
ceccolini coaches film in December
January I don't love this quarterback
class like everyone else does I think
it's good I don't think it I don't love
it I don't see like my Holmes and Watson
and I know what I mean and I was way too
low on mahomes but the overall I don't
know man
I like to a lot and I like what burrows
done for his stock but you can pick
apart Herbert Eason love you could pick
apart their game yep something we do
with Draft 400 and we've already like
started working on that and one question
that Melo and I like you said one thing
I think we've gotten better at the first
question we asked each other on a player
is was he great at and with the
quarterbacks it's not a lot of answers
on that question like well is he great
at what's this great trait character for
two for two its accuracy to all three
levels of the field yeah and Todd which
is an touch which is like pretty much
like point a that you want to see most
of the time that's why we just sit there
and go to number one to number one
exactly and it would burrow like I think
we're getting there like I love it there
he throws the deep ball and him it's
gonna be character people are gonna love
it but people love Mitch travesties
character and Ally he might get people
fired in Chicago so yeah and you gotta
have a great trait to play quarterback
that's that and something we're gonna do
on Wednesday as a segment just to kind
of give a teaser here we're gonna pair
our quarterbacks with teams to show you
just how they'd fit scheme wise drive
value wise because all these guys have a
chance to be great
you see that but where should they land
to something we really want to talk
about in depth on Wednesday yeah it's
gonna be a lot of fun give me a good
week of shows Connor and I'll be back
Wednesday
Connor mellow and I will be back Friday
and then we are over to London for our
event don't forget we'll be there Sunday
from 4 to 6 at O'Neill's pub I got left
go is gonna be there it's gonna be a
great time come watch some NFL games
with us we'll have koozies and stickers
and things to hand out so you don't want
to miss it
and as always make sure you are
subscribing wherever you get your
podcast and also on Bleacher Report's
youtube channel just look for the stick
to football playlist